I'm going to show you where I put my
code over here in the octopus in get
notes instead of returning model dot get
all notes I'm going to instead return
model dot get all notes dot reverse so
my octopus when it passes all of my
notes over to my view it actually
reverses it for the view the view
doesn't have to worry about it now I
would like you to try to implement
another feature we're going to add a
date to every new note that we create
and we're going to display that date too
now let's just talk generally about how
we're gonna do that and then I'll set
you off to do it yourself so first of
all we're gonna need to store some kind
of date when we make a new note now I'm
gonna open up the console because one
great way to do this would be using date
dot now when you run date now it returns
a big number which represents this
current moment in time if I run it again
you'll see that the number has gotten a
little bit bigger so that's how we store
our date we're gonna need to put that
inside of our add new note function
that's where it creates the object
literal which becomes our note so now
we're not just storing content we're
going to store a date so that changes
our code so that way it's storing a date
every time we add a new note we don't
need to change the get notes function
because it just returns all of our notes
including their content and their date
and it reverses them for the view and
speaking of the view that actually meets
the change as well now that we're
storing dates for our notes we probably
want to display that date as well now
you can add that in the HTML string down
here that we're generating I'd suggest
putting it in an element with a class of
note - date so that way the CSS that I
included gets applied properly now one
last thing before when we were
experimenting with us we were creating
notes that didn't have dates applied so
if you go back into your console here
and you run the local storage clear
it'll wipe away all of the persistent
storage so when we press refresh we
don't have any notes anymore and all of
our notes will then have that date
property that you're adding and now I
leave it
you go forth and add date stamps to your
notes